Satya, let me start by asking you, "Who is Satya Nadella?"
Tell us a little bit about yourself.
I'm 46 years old; I've been at Microsoft for 22 of those 46 years.
I've been married for 22 years to a wife I've known ever since high school.
We have three kids.
Like anyone else, my experience and how I think, have all been shaped by my life's experience.
And the one thing that I would say that defines me is, I love to learn.
I get excited about new things.
I buy more books than I read or finish.
I sign up for more online courses than I can actually finish.
But the thing about being able to watch people do great things,...
...learn new concepts, is something that truly excites me.
Now, CEO of Microsoft, tell me, tell us, why did you want this role?
It's a question I asked myself very deeply when the opportunity came up.
And when I think about the core of why I'm here, it is about impact.
And in a software-powered world, what's a better place than Microsoft...
...in terms of being able to take all of this human potential that we have...
...in 100 and 130, soon to be 130,000 people,...
...and apply it to a world that's rapidly becoming more software-driven.
And the opportunity is what fundamentally drives me...
...and got me to take this, raise my hand for this job.